Et voici la réponse :
la réponse est la technologie.
Je sais, je sais -
ouais, ouais, la technologie, l'automatisation baise les gens, bla bla
ce n'est pas ça.
Je ne parle pas de ce type de technologie
qui a enveloppé nos vies, et dont les gens viennent à TED pour en entendre parler.
Je ne parle pas de la technologie des choses,
aussi profonde soit-elle.
Je parle d'une autre technologie.
Je parle de la technologie des idées.
Je l'appelle « la technologie de l'idée »
comme c'est malin.
(Rires)
En plus de créer des choses, la science crée des idées.
La science crée des façons de comprendre.
Dans les sciences sociales,
les façons de comprendre ce qui est créé sont des moyens de nous comprendre.
Ils ont une énorme influence sur la façon dont nous pensons, ce à quoi nous aspirons
et comment nous agissons.
Si vous pensez que votre pauvreté est la volonté de Dieu, vous priez.
Si vous pensez que votre pauvreté est le résultat de votre propre insuffisance,
vous tombez dans le désespoir.
Si vous pensez que votre pauvreté est le résultat d'une oppression et domination,
alors vous vous révoltez.
Que votre réponse à la pauvreté soit résignée ou révoltée,
ça dépend de comment vous comprenez les origines de votre pauvreté.
C'est le rôle que jouent les idées en nous façonnant en tant qu'êtres humains,
voilà pourquoi la technologie de l'idée peut être la plus profondément importante
que la science nous ait donnée.
Il y a quelque chose de spécial à propos de la technologie de l'idée,
qui la rend différente par rapport à la technologie des choses.
Avec les choses, si la technologie craint,
elle disparaît, non ?
Les mauvaises technologies disparaissent.
Avec les idées -
les idées fausses sur les êtres humains ne vont pas disparaître
si les gens croient qu'elles sont vraies.
Parce que si les gens croient qu'elles sont vraies,
ils créent des manières de vivre et des institutions
qui sont cohérentes avec ces idées fausses.
C'est comment la révolution industrielle a créé un système d'usines
dans lequel il n'y avait vraiment rien à obtenir de votre journée de travail,
à part la paye.
Parce que le père - un des pères
de la révolution industrielle, Adam Smith -
était convaincu que les êtres humains sont par nature fainéants,
et ne feraient rien sauf si vous valorisiez leur temps,
et la manière de le valoriser
était en motivant, en leur donnant des récompenses.
C'était la seule raison pour que quelqu'un fasse quelque chose.
Nous avons créé un système cohérent avec cette fausse image de la nature humaine.
Une fois ce système de production en place,
il n'y avait vraiment pas d'autre façon pour les gens d'opérer,
sauf si cette façon était cohérente avec la vision d'Adam Smith.
Ainsi, l'exemple du travail est simplement un exemple
de comment les idées fausses peuvent créer une situation
qui finit par les rendre vraies.
Ce n'est pas vrai
que vous « ne pouvez juste plus obtenir une bonne aide ».
C'est vrai
que « vous ne pouvez plus obtenir une bonne aide »
quand vous donnez aux gens un travail qui est dégradant et inhumain.
Et curieusement, Adam Smith -
le même gars qui nous a donné cette incroyable invention,
la production de masse, la division du travail
- comprenait ça.
Il disait de quelqu'un qui travaillait sur une chaîne de montage :
« Il devient aussi stupide qu'il est possible à un humain de devenir. »
Remarquez que le mot ici est « devenir ».
Qu'il l'ait voulu ou non, ce qu'Adam Smith nous disait ici,
est la forme même de l'institution, au sein de laquelle les gens travaillent,
qui crée des gens qui correspondent à la demande de cette institution
et prive les gens de l'opportunité
d'avoir les types de satisfaction que nous prenons pour acquis.
La truc à propos de la science - la science naturelle --
est que nous pouvons raconter de fantastiques théories sur le cosmos,
en ayant une confiance totale
que le cosmos est complètement indifférent à nos théories.
Il va travailler de la même manière
peu importe les théories que nous avons sur le cosmos.
Nous devons nous inquiéter des théories que nous avons sur la nature humaine,
parce que la nature humaine sera modifiée par nos théories,
qui sont conçues pour expliquer et nous aider à comprendre les êtres humains.
L'éminent anthropologue, Clifford Geertz, a déclaré il y a quelques années,
que les êtres humains sont les « animaux inachevés ».
Il voulait dire par là que c'est uniquement humain
d'avoir une nature humaine
qui est bien le produit de la société dans laquelle les gens vivent.
Que la nature humaine, c'est-à-dire notre nature humaine,
est bien plus créée que découverte.
Nous concevons la nature humaine
en concevant les institutions dans lesquelles les gens vivent et travaillent.
Et donc vous les gens -
qui vous rapprochez le plus des maîtres de l'univers -
vous, les gens, devriez vous poser une question,
quand vous retournerez à la maison pour diriger vos entreprises.
Quel genre de nature humaine voulez-vous aider à concevoir ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)